okay so you've seen the tone of the
video and you're thinking he's gone
eh DS finally got to me cracked but this
is an absolutely true story that I've
never really told anybody before now in
order for you to understand it I first
need to give you some backstory Wells
growing up we had two cats Henry and
snowy and I loved them to absolute bits
and because I love them so much I got
into something of a nighttime routine
which I did every night from the age of
about six or seven to the age of
eighteen every night before I could go
to sleep I would do several things
firstly I would kiss my teddy goodnight
obviously then I'd go and find Henry and
kiss him goodnight and I tell him about
my day so what I've done in school and I
think fun idol and my friends it was
almost like writing in a diary and if he
wasn't sleeping in my room which often
did then I would go out into the house
in my pants and find him incidentally
finding a jet black cat in a completely
dark house is not easy
then after I'd done that with Henry I
would do exactly the same thing to snow
but I would tell him about what I was
doing the following day
so any homework that I had Julian and he
tests that were coming up basically my
schedule for the whole day I'm not crazy
now this is all fine and dandy when we
all lived in the same house but when I
was about 10 we moved a couple of miles
down the road and only Henry came with
us
basically snowy you kind of adopted some
next-door neighbors because a really
nice garden and he'd spend pretty much
all this time sunbathing in their garden
so when we moved the decision was kind
of made that they would adopt him and
only one cat would come with us
naturally this threw something of a
spanner in the works of my nighttime
schedule as before I would kiss teddy
good night and I guess Henry good night
Ellen on a day
but with snowy I took what I thought was
the only logical option
I found the window in the new house
which approximately pointed towards the
direction of our old house and I would
talk to the window as if it was snowy
again most of the time just in my pants
are awful I'm not
I'm not crazy now that's perfectly
rational and same behavior continued up
until I was 18 and I was doing my
a-levels and it was at this point that
my parents just by chance bumped into
our old neighbors and they unfortunately
told us that snowy had died a couple of
months before just as old age so for the
six months or so leading up to that
chance meeting I had been talking to a
window pretending it was my cat whereas
actually I've been talking to a window
pretending it was a cat which was it was
dead six months that was an awkward
final time saying goodnight bye Jane so
it turns out you're Ted however I
genuinely really believe that this
process of talking to my two cats one of
him just happened to be dead some of the
time was a really big part of my
academic success at school and getting
into Oxford and it stems from the fact
that I think learning is a three-step
process step one preconditioning
yourself to learn so this is the
environment that you are going to be
working in your attitude towards the
work what you've eaten any preparations
that you've put into working in that
session step two actually learning new
material and then step three processing
that material so categorizing in filing
the new information that you have away
in your brain such that you you know
know where it sits in relation to
everything else that you know now each
of those steps are very important in
that own right you have to be in the
right frame of mind to work you have to
pay attention and concentrate when
you're asked taking in new information
and you do need to be able to categorize
what you've learned you need to be able
to access it again and know where it
sits in relation to all the other
knowledge you have in your life however
there's a fourth step which is arguably
the most important of all and it means
that learning actually works in a cycle
one you precondition yourself to learn
to you absorb new information three you
process that information and then four
you evaluate your learning experience
and that evaluation then feeds back into
how you precondition ourselves to learn
in future by evaluating what I mean is
reviewing the information that you've
just learned so going over the bits that
you understand and maybe the bits that
you don't understand quite so well
almost to teach
information again to yourself and then
use the information that you've kind of
glean from that introspection to inform
how you learn in the future so
identifying processes that you learn
very quickly so you know that you don't
need to allocate too much time to
learning new processes like those but
also recognizing processes that you took
awhile to learn and then saying well I
need to allocate more time to those in
the future what I was doing by talking
to my cats was exactly this I was
reviewing the information that I had
learned in that day and explaining it to
Henry and then taking that review of the
information and using it to inform my
plans for the next day so when I talked
to snowy about what I kind of scheduled
for the next day saying to myself well
actually this biddin go quite so well I
think tomorrow maybe I should look over
that again now I'm not necessarily
suggesting that you talk to cats though
if you had cats do that really good
listeners but that you should consider
daily review and evaluation of the work
that you've done in that day school or
at uni and that doesn't have to be cat
it could be writing in a diary or just
setting five to ten minutes aside before
you go to bed to think about what you've
done that day when I was in Oxford I
actually kept a revision diary which
allowed me to write down what I done in
that day and then it actually allowed me
to track ahead so I knew that a week or
a month in a in the future I'd review
the material that I'd done on that given
day which is an excellent tip by the way
but it also at the end of every day
allows me to review what I done and then
use that review to inform what I was
going to do the next day this is just
something that I personally benefited
from a lot particularly when I was in
school and I thought that maybe you guys
would too if you did like this topic and
the style of video but I highly highly
recommend you check out Tom Frank's
channel college info geek which is full
of so many videos about study tips and
improving our productivity and he's a
lot better at this than I am if you did
like this video which I appreciate is a
little bit different for this channel
then do give it a thumbs up so I know
that you guys like this kind of content
and also comment down there if you have
revision tips that you've personally
found particularly useful and successful
then do leave them down there and
I love it nothing more than if we could
learn from each other as a community of
people who are engaged and passionate
about learning so shout it put them down
there thanks very much for watching and
I will see you next time
you